You happy with what you got because the
owners of this country don't want that.
I'm talking about the real owners now,
the real owners,
the big wealthy business interests that
control things and make all the
important decisions they get.
The politicians,
the politicians are put there to give
you the idea that you have freedom of
choice.
You don't.
You have no choice.
You have owners,
they own you.
They own everything.
They own all the important land.
They own and control the corporations.
They've long since bought and paid for
the Senate,
the Congress,
the state houses and city halls.
They got the back pockets and they own
all the big media company,
so they control just about all of the
news and information.
You get to here.
They got you by the balls.
They spend billions of dollars every
year lobbying to get what they want.
Well,
we know what they want.
They want more for themselves and less
for everybody else,
but I'll tell you what they don't want.
They don't want a population of citizens
capable of critical thinking.
They don't want well informed,
well educated people capable of critical
thinking.
Then I didn't,
she didn't that that doesn't help them.
That's against their interest,
what they want.
They want obedient workers,
obedient workers,
people who are just smart enough to run
the machines and do the paperwork and
just dumb enough to passively accept all
these increasingly shittier jobs with
lower pay,
the longer hours to reduce benefits to
the end of overtime and the vanishing
pension.
That disappears the minute you go to
collect it and now they're coming for
your social security money.
They want you to fucking retirement
money.
They wanted back so they can give it to
their criminal friends on Wall Street
and you know something.
They'll get it.
They'll get it all from you sooner or
later because they own this fucking
place.
It's a big club and you ain't in it.
You and I are not in the big club by the
way.
It's the same big club they used to beat
you over the head with all day long.
When they tell you what to believe all
day long,
beaten over the head and their media
telling you what to believe,
what they think and what to buy.
The table is tilted,
folks,
the game is rigged.
Nobody seems to notice.
Nobody seems to care.
Good,
honest,
hard working.
People continue to elect these rich cock
suckers who don't give a fuck about
them.
It's called the American dream because
you have to be asleep to believe it.
Things are nothing more than ordinary
jungle beast savages.
No different from a cro.
Magnon people live 25,000
years ago on the place to seem forest
seat and grubs off a rotten logs,
no different.
Our DNA hasn't changed substantially in
100,000
years.
We're still operating out of the lower
brain.
The reptilian brain fight or flight,
kill or be killed.
Now we like to think we've evolved in
advance because we can build a computer
flying airplane,
travel underwater.
We can write a sonnet painter painting,
composed an opera,
but you know something.
We're out of the jungle on this planet,
barely out of the fucking jungle.
What we are is semis,
civilized beast with baseball caps and
automatic weapons.
It just seems to me,
seems to me that only a really low Iq
population could have taken this
beautiful continent,
this magnificent American landscape that
we inherited.
Well,
actually we stole it from the Mexicans
and the Indians,
but hey,
it was nice.
One we stolen.
Only a nation of unenlightened halfwits
could could've taken this beautiful
place and turned it into what it is
today.
A shopping mall I'll after mile of ball
after ball.
Many,
many malls,
major malls in mini malls.
They put the mini malls in between their
major malls and then between the many
walls they put them in the marts and
then between the mini marts you got the
car,
lots,
gas stations,
muffler shops,
laundromats,
cheap hotels,
fast food joint strip clubs,
and dirty bookstores.
America,
the beautiful one,
big transcontinental commercial
cesspool.
And how did the people feel about all
this?
How do people feel about living in a
coast to coast shopping mall?
Well,
they think it's just fucking Dan.
Dave,
they think it is cool as can be because
Americans love the mall.
They love the wall.
That's where they get to satisfy their
two most prominent addictions.
At the same time,
shopping and eating.
We got to be the most interesting
critters on the planet,
and then we wonder why Ufo doesn't just
land and say hello.